imaginez des chevaux en liberté galoper
sur d'immenses étendues sauvages
imaginez maintenant que ces chevaux
soient poursuivis par un hélicoptère à
bord de sniper il visent les chevaux du
groupe et les tu
tous en fait tout ça c'est bien réel et
ça se passe loin des caméras c'est même
soutenu et organisé par un gouvernement
mais ça fait polémique quand j'ai
découvert cette pratique j'ai été très
étonné et même assez choqué en creusant
un peu j'ai pu voir qu'il y avait eu des
P et des rassemblements pour tenter de
stopper ces tirs par
hélicoptère mais j'ai aussi découvert
des pétitions et des rassemblements pour
soutenir leur mise en
place et en fait derrière ces chevaux il
y a toute une histoire il n'ont pas
toujours été là ce dimanche dans ce
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
j'ai voulu comprendre ce qu'il y avait
derrière ces abattages massifs de
chevaux je vous
explique